أجنبي
[موسيقى]
أنا أعيش في الجنة وقد قطعت للتو طريقًا مني،
لدينا محلي، وهي عبارة عن
قاعة محيط داخلية متشكلة بشكل طبيعي، إنها
مكان جميل وجميل لا أحد
يذهب إلى هناك أبدًا، وأصبح هذا مكان قدسي ومكاني
للتمرين و  مجرد
مكان أذهب إليه خلال اليوم ومجرد
شيء أفعله، وفي
أحد الأيام رأيت الزعانف الظهرية العلوية المميزة لسمكة
قرش ليمونية بالغة
وقلت لنفسي جيدًا،
أتساءل عما إذا كانوا سينجبون أطفالًا
لأن أشجار المانغروف و
تعتبر المياه الضحلة موطنًا مثاليًا لأسماك قرش
الليمون الصغيرة، إلا إذا كانت
تقضي ساعات وساعات يومًا بعد يوم
يوميًا حتى رأيت واحدة
واعتقدت أنه سيكون من الرائع حقًا الحصول على
بعض اللقطات الجيدة ولذلك حصلت على كاميرا GoPro
وبعضها  قمت بربط سمكة بثقل من
الرصاص وبدأت في وضع هذه
الأشياء في جميع أنحاء الخور وفي جميع
أنحاء هذه الأماكن على أمل
التقاط لقطات قريبة
لأسماك القرش الليمونية الصغيرة هذه
وبعد العديد من المحاولات نجحت في النهاية
وتمكنت من اصطيادها  بعض
اللقطات الرائعة لأسماك القرش الليمونية الصغيرة هذه،
اعتقدت أنني
ربما دخلت الماء بالفعل،
لذا اضطررت في النهاية إلى الحصول على
قطعة من السمك في زجاجة بلاستيكية،
وثقبت الزجاجة البلاستيكية ووضعت بعض
الأسماك هناك ووضعت هذه الزجاجة
بينهما  ساقاي
ولكن في النهاية ستأتي أسماك القرش هذه ببطء وتبدأ في
التفاعل معي،
وتقترب مني، ويلكموني
برؤوسهم، ويضربونني
بذيولهم ليروا ما أنا عليه، لأنهم
كانوا فضوليين لأنهم لم يروني أبدًا  قبل أن
أكون هذا الكائن الغريب غير العادي
واستغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً للمجيء لعدة
أيام وساعات عديدة وضربوني بالفعل
وضربوني وأشياء
أدركوا أنني لا أشكل تهديدًا
وببطء اقتربوا مني
وبدأوا  للتفاعل معي وهو يتسلق
من خلال ساقي ومن حولي وفي
كل مكان، لقد
كان وقتًا رائعًا
جلبت لي أسماك القرش الليمونية فرحة كبيرة لقد
كسروا الوحدة والصمت الذي
كان الوباء والإغلاق كما
تعلمون وحصلت على فرحة كبيرة و
الدعم العاطفي من قضاء الوقت مع هؤلاء
الحد يظهر أنهم مجرد
مخلوقات جميلة جميلة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية